Kim Kardashian transforms into X-Men's
mystique and attends Tracy Ellis Ross's
non-costume b-day Bash
in her costume it's a different
experience for sure on Saturday Kim went
all out for Halloween dressed as the
Marvel character in a skin-tight blue
bodysuit heels and matching face makeup
complete with slicked back red hair and
Green contact lenses what's the matter
baby you don't think I look pretty like
this
naturally the skims founder documented
the look on Instagram with a full photo
shoot why not
and Kim she took that whole ensemble out
on the town there was just one small
issue she hit up Tracy Alice Ross's 50th
birthday dinner where literally no one
else was in costume
is anyone else getting major L Woods
Legally Blonde Vibes
thanks for inviting me girls this party
is super fun Kim shared this selfie with
a birthday girl writing quote that time
I showed up to a birthday dinner in full
costume when it wasn't a costume party
I'm turning 50 this year so I feel like
I know I feel like I I'm 22. yeah but I
have the substantialness of a grown
person you do feel 20. you got big 22
energy right and Kim she made the most
of her costume swinging by a Halloween
bash where she posed with Diddy dressed
as the Joker and according to Kim he
never broke character
so tonight
gonna be a special night
everybody's so serious yeah Diddy might
be the only one who can compete with
Kim's costume commitment you know that's
that that's what I'm about he's
he's behind the scenes look at the
happy Halloween
before I go into
full brand as you can see
um I just want to tell everybody how a
a very safe Halloween weekend and I'm
saying be nice be kind
um drink responsibly
you know I'm saying let's just buy very
higher move with love
let's have some fun but back to Kim oh
thank you on Sunday the reality star had
a Halloween bash at her home featuring a
graveyard a hallway lined with mummies a
giant Skull Candy board and her famous
fam look who showed up yep that's court
and Travis dressed as Chucky and Tiffany
and Kim's daughter North was
unrecognizable as an alien this is
actually so creepy Norris this this is
so crazy let me see your hands
this is so crazy so it's safe to say
between her elaborate costumes and
parties Kim is one of the reigning
Queens of Halloween
[Music]